700 g 96 cm d'envergure une autonomie
d'une bonne trentaine de minutes et une
technologie embarquée qui capte la
lumière réfléchie par la végétation ici
du blé ce drone est bien entendu équipé
d'un GPS afin d'établir une cartographie
du champ survolet vous avez une
cartographie qui est faite au mère Carr
près donc ça vous mesure
la ur de chlorophy mère Carr par mètre
carré donc c'est quelque part beaucoup
plus précis on a une une
représentativité de la parcelle qui est
plus réelle cartes de réserve utile qui
peuvent servir à moduler l'irrigation
l'agriculteur pourra donc moduler de
manière très fine les doses d'engrais à
apporter dans les parcelles mais aussi
les éventuels traitements de déserbage
le drone n'est cependant qu'un atout
supplémentaire de l'agriculture de
précision aujourd'hui les tracteurs les
pulvérisateurs les épendeurs d'engrais
sont reliés par informatique et peuvent
utiliser les données GPS fournies par
les drones c'est ce concept global qui
constitue l'avenir de l'agriculture
quand on est passé du du cheval au
tracteur l'agriculteur a aussi évolué le
gap il est peut-être aussi important
entre un cheval et un tracteur qu'entre
un tracteur et l'électronique embarqué
maintenant l'idée de l'agriculture de
précision c'est d'apporter vraiment la
juste dose au bon au bon endroit quoi et
pour nous c'est c'est fondamental parce
que ça permet sans doute de sortir par
le haut des contraintes
environnementales auqu les agurs sont
soumis aujourd'hui dans cette partie est
de la BOS il va falloir s'habituer à ces
étranges oiseaux dans le ciel Serge go a
décidé de franchir le pas il sera l'un
des tout premiers agriculteurs à
posséder un drone
agronomique